Speaker 1: I am not being hyperbolic here. I
am going to show you clips of what I believe
is Donald Trump's worst interview that I've
ever seen him give. And I'm not going to say
it's significantly worse than the Jonathan
Swan Axios interview. It may be equally bad,
but this is at least equally bad in terms of
being Trump's worst interview that I've ever seen.
I read that this took place and I couldn't believe
it. I had to go and find the clip for myself.
I read that Sean Hannity asked Trump
about Biden's strategy of metaphorically
banging your head against the wall
and expecting results from that. It
was a metaphor for the metaphor of
banging your head against the wall.
Donald Trump answered that the wall would have
been done in three weeks if he had been reelected.
Please understand what I'm saying. Hannity
talks about metaphorically banging your head
against the wall. And Trump answers about the
literal wall that he claims he was building on
the US-Mexico border and people are questioning
Joe Biden's cognitive state. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: So, you know, it's you know, you
keep banging your head against the wall.
Why would you expect a different result?
Speaker 6: So we would have had the wall completed
in three weeks that was largely completed.
Speaker 1: So guys, it's this is a former
president, the former president. At another point
during the interview, Hannity says Trump created
monoclonal antibodies. Now I've heard Trump be
wrongly credited with creating the vaccines,
which he didn't do. Hannity is saying Trump
created the monoclonal antibodies as well.
I thought it was Regeneron. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: You left office with three vaccines
and monoclonal antibodies that you had
created, which to this day, I think, is the
best therapeutic I advise people to talk to.
Speaker 1: It's a therapeutic. What Trump now
created the antibodies to like. What? What
is happening? People watched this. People
watch this just on the basis of those two clips
alone. This is the most insane interview I've
seen Trump do. Right up there with the Jonathan
Swan interview. But then you, if I told you this,
you'd say, David, sir, it's 20 22. This can't
be going on. Trump is still bragging about the
dementia test. He's still talking about it.
Speaker 3: Do you believe he's struggling
cognitively because that question was raised about
you, and I've been around you long enough to know
that not it's not a problem for you at all.
Speaker 6: Well, I went and took a test, and as
Dr. Ronny Jackson, his great, great guy, now he's
a congressman and they love him in Texas. But
he said he aced it and I don't think he ever
saw anyone age that I immediately said because
they started testing. The false narrative
Speaker 1: goes he's still bragging about
the dimensions as he thinks it's an IQ test.
He he thinks that doing well on a test meant
to screen out relatively serious dementia that
he's worthy of Mensa membership. I mean, it's
twenty two, and he's still doing it in a moment
totally beyond parody in criticizing Joe Biden's
thus far handling of the Ukraine Russia situation.
Trump says he never had a problem with Ukraine.
What about the impeachment related to Ukraine?
Speaker 6: What what his things would have
happened? You wouldn't have had inflation. You
wouldn't have had Ukraine problems with Russia.
It was all working out. Everything was fine.
Speaker 1: The guy was impeached over his
problems with Ukraine, continuing. Now that
I've never seen an interview like that, it's
every answer is from another planet.
Trump says windmills are ruining
the atmosphere. Wind farms wind power.
Speaker 6: And if you can start that up
again and stop with all of the windmills all
over the place that are ruining the atmosphere,
you look at what's happening, why these beautiful
prairies and planes and these gorgeous areas of
our country where they have these rusting hulks
put up all over the place where they're noisy,
they're killing the birds. I mean, I don't get the
environmental said. It's a very expensive form,
probably the most expensive form of energy.
Speaker 1: Now understand there's we could just
do an hour on wind energy, understand that each of
these things has been studied first and foremost,
when technologies are new or they are nowhere near
full efficiency. So without a doubt, wind power
will become more efficient, meaning being able
to harvest more power generate more power from
the same amount of wind. That's that's
we've seen it with solar panels. We've seen
it all over the place. The bird stuff has been
studied extensively, and while it is true that
some birds are killed due to wind farms,
the number of animals killed by fossil fuels
is orders of magnitude greater. On a per energy
basis, it's been studied. But this is the stuff
that the Fox audience accepts uncritically.
Now, last clip here, and this is again, I
I can't believe we are. It's if there's ever been
evidence that we're in a simulation, it's that
Trump still doing this stuff. Trump again brags
about the size of the crowd at the insurrection.
Speaker 6: And with a lot of less than 20000
troops, also, the fact is I knew it was going
to be a massive rally because this was a protest
rally against the election, which they considered
to be totally rigged. They were right. And this
was a protest against the election. And I was
told by so many people, Oh, we're going down on
the 6th, we're going down. And that's why I met
with the top people, the top people and military
and other places. And I said, I think this is
going to be a lot of people coming down. I can
tell you I spoke, I believe it was the biggest
crowd I've ever spoken to. It was massive, the
Speaker 1: absolute biggest crowd ever incited by
a president to attempt an insurrection. We have
never seen anything like this, truly. And the
majority of the Republican Party, based on all
recent polling, wants four more years of that.
And they may get it. They may get it depending
on what happens in 2022. And of course, what
happens with Trump's health and whether Joe Biden
runs again and all these different things. But
more than half of them want it, and they
may get it, which is absolutely horrifying